fear and desire create stress why
because fear is saying I don't want
something to be the way it might be or
the way it is and desire is saying I do
want something to be the way it's not
right you don't ever desire what you
already got
and you know fear what's not happening
it's something is happening and you have
resistance to it that's what creates
fear something isn't happening and you
want it to that's what creates desire
both of those are coming out of yourself
that's your personal self fears and
desires there is no stress without fears
and desires there's just the beauty of
the experience the awesomeness I mean do
you feel stressed when you look at a
beautiful sunset do you feel stressed
when you hold your beloved in your arms
oh I held you too long you don't you
don't do that all right because you are
open you're receptive you're completely
open to the experience